fourteen years ago
i stood in the supreme court to argue my
first case
and it wasn't just any case it was a
case that experts called
one of the most important cases the
supreme court had ever heard
it considered whether guantanamo was
constitutional
and whether the geneva conventions
applied to the war on terror
it was just a handful of years after the
horrific attacks of september 11th
the supreme court had seven republican
appointees
and two democratic ones and my client
happened to be
osama bin laden's driver my opponent was
the solicitor general of the united
states america's top courtroom lawyer
he'd argued 35 cases i wasn't even 35
years old
and to make matters worse the senate for
the first time
since the civil war passed a bill to try
and remove the case
from the docket of the supreme court now
the speaking coaches say
i'm supposed to build tension and not
tell you what happens
but the thing is we want how today i'm
going to talk about
how to win an argument at the supreme
court or anywhere
the conventional wisdom is that you
speak
with confidence that's how you persuade
i think that's wrong i think confidence
is the
enemy of persuasion persuasion is about
empathy about getting into people's
heads
that's what makes ted what it is it's
why you're listening to this talk
you could have read it on the cold page
but you didn't
same thing with supreme court arguments
we write written briefs
with cold pages but we also have an oral
argument
we don't just have a system in which the
justices
write questions and you write answers
why because
argument is about interaction i want to
take you behind the scenes
to tell you what i did and how these
lessons are generalizable
not just for winning an argument in
court but for something far
more profound now obviously it's going
to involve practice
but not just any practice we'll do my
first practice session for guantanamo i
flew up to harvard and had
all these legendary professors throwing
questions at me
and even though i had read everything
rehearsed a million times
i wasn't persuading anyone my arguments
weren't resonating
i was desperate i had done everything
possible read every book rehearsed a
million times
and it wasn't going anywhere so
ultimately i stumbled on this guy he was
an acting coach he wasn't even a lawyer
he never set foot in the supreme court
and he came into my office one day
wearing a billowy white shirt and a
bolo tie and he looked at me with my
folded arms and said look neil i can
tell
that you don't think this is going to
work but just humor me
tell me your argument so i grabbed my
legal pad
and i started reading my argument he
said what are you doing i said i'm
telling you my argument
he said your argument is a legal pad i
said no but my argument's on a legal pad
he said neil look at me tell me
your argument and so i did and instantly
i realized
my points were resonating i was
connecting to another human being
and he could see the smile starting to
form
as i was saying my words and he said
okay neil
now do your argument holding my hand
and i said what and he said yeah hold my
hand
i was desperate so i did it and i
realized wow
that's connection that's the power of
how to persuade
and it helped but truthfully i still got
nervous as the argument date approached
and i knew that even though argument was
about getting into someone else's shoes
and empathizing
i needed to have a solid core first so i
did something outside of my comfort
zone i wore jewelry not just anything
but a bracelet that my father had worn
his whole life
until he passed away just a few months
before the argument
i put on a tie that my mom had given me
just for the occasion
and i took out my legal pad and wrote my
children's names on it
because that's why i was doing this for
them to leave the country better
than i had found it i got to court and i
was calm
the bracelet the tie the children's
names it all
centered me like a rock climber
extending beyond the precipice
if you have a solid hold you can reach
out
and because argument is about persuasion
i knew i had to avoid emotion displays
of emotion fail
it's kind of like writing an email and
all bold in all caps
it persuades no one it's then about you
the speaker
not about the listener or the receiver
now look in some settings
the solution is to be emotional you're
arguing with your parents
and you use emotion and it works why
because your parents love you
but supreme court justices don't love
you they don't like to think of
themselves as the type of people
persuaded by emotion
and i reverse engineered that insight
too setting a trap for my opponent to
provoke his emotional reaction
so i could be seen as the calm and
steady voice of the law
and it worked and i remember sitting in
the courtroom
to learn that we had won that the
guantanamo tribunals were coming down
and i went out onto the courthouse steps
and there was a media firestorm
500 cameras and they're all asking me
what does the decision mean what does it
say
well the decision was 185 pages long i
hadn't had time to read it nobody had
but i knew what it meant and here's what
i said on the steps of the court
here's what happened today you had the
lowest of the low
this guy who was accused of being bin
laden's driver one of the most
horrible men around and he sued not just
anyone
but the nation indeed the world's most
powerful man the president of the united
states
and he brings in not in some rinky-dink
traffic court but in the highest court
of the land
the supreme court of the united states
and he wins
that's something remarkable about this
country
in many other countries this driver
would have been shot
just for bringing his case and more to
the point for me his lawyer would have
been shot
but that's what makes america different
what makes america special
because of that decision the geneva
conventions applied to the war on terror
which meant the end of ghost prisons
worldwide the end of waterboarding
worldwide
and an end to those guantanamo military
tribunals
by methodically building the case and
getting into the justices heads
we were able to quite literally changed
the world
sounds easy right you can practice a lot
avoid displays of emotion and you too
can win any argument
i'm sorry to say it's not that simple my
strategies aren't foolproof
and while i've won more supreme court
cases than most anyone
i've also lost a lot too indeed after
donald trump was elected
i was constitutionally speaking
terrified
please understand this is not about left
versus right or anything like that
i'm not here to talk about that but just
a week into the new
president's term you might remember
those scenes at the airports
president trump had campaigned on a
pledge
saying quote i donald j trump are
calling for a complete and total
shutdown
of all muslim immigration to the united
states and he also said quote i think
islam hates us
and he made good on that promise banning
immigration from seven countries
with overwhelmingly muslim populations
my legal team and others went into court
right away and sued
and got that first travel ban struck
down trump revised it
we went into court again and got that
struck down he revised it again and
changed it adding north korea
because we all know the united states
has a tremendous immigration problem
with north korea
but it did enable his lawyers to go to
the supreme court and say
see this isn't discriminating against
muslims it includes these other people
too
now i thought we had the killer answer
to that
i won't bore you with the details but
the thing is
we lost five votes to four and i was
devastated
i was worried my powers of persuasion
had waned
and then two things happened the first
was
i noticed a part of the supreme court's
travel ban opinion
that discussed the japanese american
internment
that was a horrific moment in our
history in which over a hundred thousand
japanese americans
had been interned in camps my favorite
person to challenge this scheme
was gordon hirabayashi a university of
washington student
he turned himself into the fbi who said
look you're a first-time offender you
can go home
and gordon said no i'm a quaker
i have to resist on just laws and so
they arrested him
and he was convicted gordon's case made
it to the supreme court
and again i'm going to do that thing
where i quash any sense of anticipation
you have
and tell you what happened gordon lost
but he lost because of a simple reason
because the solicitor general that top
courtroom lawyer for the government told
the supreme court
that the japanese american internment
was justified by military necessity
and that was so even though his own
staff had discovered
that there was no need for the
japanese-american internment
and that the fbi and the intelligence
community
all believed that and indeed that it was
motivated
by racial prejudice has staff begged the
solicitor general
tell the truth don't suppress evidence
what did the solicitor general do
nothing he went in and told the military
necessities story
and so the court upheld gordon
hirabayashi's conviction
and the next year upheld fred
korematsu's
internment now why was i thinking about
that because nearly 70 years later
i got to hold the same office head of
the solicitor general's office
and i got to set the record straight
explaining
that the government had misrepresented
the facts
in the japanese internment cases and
when i thought about the supreme court's
travel ban opinion
i realized something the supreme court
in that opinion went
out of its way to overrule the koramatsu
case
now not only have the justice department
said
the japanese internment was wrong the
supreme court
said so too that's a crucial lesson
about arguments timing all of you when
you're arguing have that important lever
to play
when do you make your argument you don't
just need the right argument
you need the right argument at the right
moment
when is it that your audience a spouse
a boss a child is going to be most
receptive
now look sometimes that's totally out of
your control delay has
costs that are too extensive and so
you've got to go in and fight
and you very well may like me get the
timing wrong
that's what we thought in the travel ban
and you see the supreme court wasn't
ready
so early in president trump's turn to
overrule
his signature initiative just as it
wasn't ready to overrule
fdr's japanese american internment
and sometimes you just have to take the
risk but it is
so painful when you lose and patience is
really hard
but that reminds me of the second lesson
even if vindication comes later
i realized how important the fight now
is
because it inspires because it educates
i remember reading a column by ann
coulter
about the muslim ban here's what she
said arguing against trump
was first generation american neil
katyal
there are plenty of 10th generation
america haters
you couldn't get one of them to argue we
should end our country
through mass immigration and that's when
emotion
which is so anathema to a good argument
was important to me it took a motion
outside the courtroom
to get me back in it when i read
coulter's words i was angry
i rebel against the idea that being a
first generation american
would disqualify me i rebel against the
idea that mass immigration
would end this country instead of
recognizing that is
literally the rock on which this country
was built
when i read coulter i thought about so
many things in my past
i thought about my dad who arrived here
with eight dollars
from india and didn't know whether to
use the colored bathroom
or the white one i thought about his
first job offer
at a slaughterhouse not a great job for
a hindu
i thought about how when we moved to a
new neighborhood in chicago with one
other indian family that family had a
cross burned on its lawn
because the races aren't very good at
distinguishing between african americans
and hindus
and i thought about all the hate mail i
got during guantanamo
for being a muslim lover again the races
aren't very good with distinctions
between
hindus and muslims either ann coulter
thought that being the child of an
immigrant was a weakness
she was profoundly profoundly wrong
it is my strength because i knew what
america was supposed to stand for i knew
that in america me a child
of a man who came here with eight
dollars in his pocket could stand in the
supreme court of the united states
on behalf of a detested foreigner like
osama bin laden's driver
and win and it made me realize even
though i may have lost the case
i was right about the muslim ban too no
matter what the court decided
they couldn't change the fact that
immigrants do strengthen this country
indeed in many ways immigrants love this
country the most
when i read ann coulter's words i
thought about the glorious words of our
constitution
the first amendment congress shall make
no law
establishing religion i thought about
our national creed
e pluribus unum out of many
come one most of all i realize the only
way you can truly
lose an argument is by giving up
so i joined a lawsuit by the u.s
congress
challenging president trump's edition of
a citizenship question
to the census a decision with huge
implications
it was a really hard case most thought
we would lose
but the thing is we won five votes to
four
the supreme court basically said
president trump
and his cabinet secretary had lied
and now i've gotten back up and rejoined
the fight and i hope each of you in your
own ways does so too
i'm getting back up because i'm a
believer that good arguments
do win out in the end the arc of justice
is long
and bends often slowly but it bends so
long as we
bend it and i've realized the question
is not how to win
every argument it's how to get back up
when you do lose
because in the long run good arguments
will win out
if you make a good argument it has the
power to outlive you
to stretch beyond your core to reach
those future minds
and that's why all this is so important
i'm not telling you how to win
arguments for the sake of winning
arguments this isn't a game
i'm telling you this because even if you
don't win right now
if you make a good argument history will
prove you right
i think back to that acting coach all
the time and i've come to realize
that the hand i was holding was the hand
of justice
that outstretched hand will come for you
it's your decision
to push it away or to keep holding it
thank you so much for listening